ist es nicht ironisch dass ausgerechnet
aus der FDP sozusagen die Klage kommt
dass es jetzt bei den
Bundesjugendspielen quasi sektorenziele
gibt und sie selber sind diejenigen die
die sektorenziele Schleifen zum Beispiel
beim Thema Klima in der Bundesregierung
ist das nicht total ironisch dieser
Traumziele beim Klimaschutz machen
keinen Sinn es ergibt keine vielleicht
auch bei den bundesjugendspiel nicht
also was völlig anderes ja
anderes Thema also wir können gerne
machen kann beim Klimaschutz machen kann
sind wir haben im Verkehrsbereich ja ähm
die sektorenziele erreicht während
corona-krise das lag aber nicht daran
dass irgendetwas verkehrspolitisches
beschlossen wurde sondern das lag daran
dass die Leute zu Hause gesessen haben
und dann hat man einen Haken machen an
den Verkehrsbereich und hat Klima
politisch eigentlich nichts erreicht
es geht um Leistungsbereitschaft es geht
darum etwas zu wollen
in Zukunft immer mehr Menschen auf
Elektromobilität umsteigen dann wandert
die Betrachtung
Mobilität vom Verkehrssektor in den
Energiesektor weil dieser Strom ja
irgendwo herkommen muss und dann kann
ich irgendwie in 20 Jahren sagen ah der
Verkehrssektor ist jetzt klimaneutral
und beim Strom ja der wird dann weiter
aus Kohlekraft
würde man da nicht hingucken müssen ich
finde es interessant jetzt sagen sie ja
in der Pandemie hat man aus Versehen den
die sektorenziele im Verkehr erreicht
das stimmt nach der Pandemie hat man sie
da nicht erreicht obwohl es ein
Verkehrsminister gegeben hätte der dafür
verantwortlich gewesen wäre und stand
heute weiß man es gibt wissenschaftlich
endlos Evidenz das Sektor Ziele Sinn
ergeben weil sie sorgen dafür dass man
eben nicht Veränderung von nuschelt und
weg redet und Weg blockiert bis es uns
in 5 Jahren als auf die Füße fällt und
wir erkennen aber auch dass der Minister
der sagen am allermeisten diese Sektoren
Ziel der boykottiert in der FDP-Minister
ist und jetzt sagt die FDP die Sektoren
ich habe fast das Gefühl da möchte man
lieber klimasch Gesetz machen was dem
Herrn Minister Wissing nicht so viel
schlechte Laune macht starten gesetzt zu
machen was tatsächlich dafür sorgt dass
wir sektorübergreifend richtig
runterkommen mit den Emissionen also die
Abschaffung der sektorenziele verbunden
mit einer krassen Ansage in Richtung
Reduzierung CO2 Sinn
das Ziel ist dass die das unterm Strich
weniger CO2 meditiert werden muss das
muss das Ergebnis sein
Vertrag ja das ist nicht die Haltung der
FDP dass die Haltung der Grünen dass die
Haltung der SPD und ist die Haltung der
FDP und ich habe auch den Eindruck dass
diese Wut bei den Menschen teilweise
daher kommt dass man sich auf bestimmte
Dinge einigt in diesem Land und dann
werden sie einfach weiter diskutiert es
gibt übrigens auch für viele Klimaschutz
ähm total interessant ja aber auch schon
wieder ironisch das sagt jemand von der
FDP na ja
die ganze Zeit auf Dinge und sie haben
sie hinterher weiter sozusagen
Zeitpunkt behandelt wo man meinte man
könnte sich auch ohne dass man
verbindliche Ziele hat darauf verlassen
dass sektorübergreifend die Regeln
eingehalten werden alles getan wird
damit man vorankommt was jetzt in den
letzten beiden Jahren aber passiert ist
vor allem Verkehrssektor wurden
letztendlich viele boykottiert ich meine
vergessen Minister missing missing hat
es ja nicht nur einerseits auf der einen
Seite irgendwie gewerkschaftlich so
brachial durch diese Situation
durchzufallen erst danach nicht
geschafft und Sofortprogramm zu
produzieren was der Auftrag gewesen wäre
um das wieder auszugleichen das heißt
die Annahme über die Art und Weise wie
man diesem dann Klimaschutz betreibt hat
sich in den letzten zwei Jahren ja
komplett verändert aber wir feststellen
es gibt stand jetzt in der Ampel kein
parteiübergreifenden Content darüber
dass man sich gewissenhaft mit allem was
man hat demokratisch gemeinschaftlich
dafür ein dass wir das Pariser
Klimaziele einhalten das sehen wir stand
jetzt einfach nicht wir merken in den
letzten zwei Jahren zwei Jahren die
Bilanz ist bekehrend wie ihr sehen dass
wir europäische Partner hinten
zurücklassen wir sind international ein
super schlechtes Beispiel dafür wenn man
feststellt so ein reiches Land wie
Deutschland hat so ein historische
Chance gerade richtig gute Politik zu
machen die ökologisch ist die
wirtschaftlich ist die nachhaltig ist
die Konzepte sind da die Möglichkeiten
sind da die Ampel wollte meine
forschungskoalition sein und was ist in
den letzten zwei Jahren passiert das ist
doch dramatisch Menschen verlieren das
Vertrauen die verlieren die Zuversicht
die verlieren die Hoffnung und man sieht
immer wieder stellt die Ampel wenn Sie
die Entscheidung hat das Koalitionsklima
vor das Weltklima also in den letzten
zwei Jahren ist folgendes passiert wir
haben das Wind an Land gesetzt
beschlossen wir haben das sind auf See
gesetzt beschlossen wir haben gerade das
Gebäude Energiegesetz beschlossen wir
haben das Energieeffizienz gesetzt
beschlossen wir haben das
deutschlandticket eingeführt wir haben
uns beeilt und beschleunigt den Ausstieg
aus der braunen Kohle wir haben uns um
den Schienen Ausbau gekümmert und viele
weitere Maßnahmen ich will dafür keine
Dankbarkeit aber ich will zumindest eine
Anerkennung der Realität
in den letzten zwei Jahren ein Krieg in
Europa stattgefunden hat dass wir eine
Situation haben in der die Leute
wirklich
voller Wut Frustration und Entfremdung
von der Demokratie unterwegs sind und
die Koalition in dieser Zeit trotzdem
sagt wir machen Klimaschutz das machen
wir trotzdem ja und dass das alles
weggewischt wird und gesagt wird es
passiert nicht das finde ich einfach hat
mit der Realität in unserem Land nichts
zu tun also in dem Land in dem man so
unterwegs ist ist doch das Problem dass
die Leute das Wort Klimaschutz hören die
Leute hören das Wort Klimaschutz und
kriegen die Krise die haben Angst um
ihre Heizung Angst um ihre Wohnung Angst
um ihre Zukunft übrigens auch viele weil
sie sehen dass es Extremwetter
Ereignisse gibt und dass das Thema Klima
wirklich ein dringendes das ist in der
Lebensrealität der Menschen mittlerweile
so das Klimaschutz ein hass-thema
geworden ist und diese Koalition kümmert
sich darum dass im Krieg in Europa die
Wohnung warm bleiben dass die Wirtschaft
im Laufen bleibt und wir machen trotzdem
Klimaschutz und dann heißt es reicht
alles nicht
wie gesagt keine Dankbarkeit aber
wenigstens Anerkennung der Realität wäre
irgendwie schön das verstehe ich das ist
nicht reicht das sagt nicht ich das sagt
ihr Expertenrat der Bundesregierung und
ich glaube es ist total gut anzuerkennen
man hat in den letzten zwei Jahren man
hatte so viele Krisen es geht schwer es
gibt vielen Menschen schlecht ich glaube
dass wir in dieser Stelle einmal kurz
überlegen müssen warum wir reden Klima
ist ja nicht ein Wohltätigkeitsprojekt
und Aktivisten gegenüber es geht darum
dass man eine Gesellschaft in ihrem
Fundament erhält dass man demokratische
Integrität beweist weil man sich an
Ziele hält die man die man sich selbst
gesetzt hat und dass man auch überlegt
wie sieht eigentlich ein grüner
Wirtschaftsstandort aus also auch wenn
es um die Gesellschaft um Arbeitsplätze
um Wohlergehen geht geht es ja nicht
darum dass man sagt und nebenbei haben
wir noch so ein bisschen wohltätig
Charity-Projekte mit Öko gemacht sondern
es geht darum dass wir feststellen wenn
die Klimaschutzpolitik die wir brauchen
nicht stattfindet in der Geschwindigkeit
und in der Konsequenz wie es notwendig
ist und fliegt der Laden um die Ohren
das heißt viel weniger als zu sagen was
passiert nichts sag ich es kann nicht
angehen dass eine Ampel los die sich
Ziele setzt die Ziele reißt wie im
Klimaschutzgesetz und dann zwei Jahre
der Gesellschaft vorlebt wie man sich
immer wieder um die im Kreis dreht wie
man sich zerstreitet wie man Menschen so
sehr die Lust nimmt an jeden Art von
Fortschritt
man gleich darf sie sagten gerade es
kann nicht sein dass wir dann immer
wieder anfangen über die Dinge zu
diskutieren gerade sie in der FDP und
das mag Gründe und gute Gründe haben
darüber können wir uns auch gleich
unterhalten aber sie stehen tatsächlich
wirklich wie keine andere Partei gehen
genau
Gründen verbrenner motor aus 220 35
reitet plötzlich alles beschlossen alles
besprochen
die FDP wieder raus und sagt machen wir
jetzt alles ganz anders machen wenn ich
so gab es eine riesige Enttäuschung auf
europäischer Ebene das wissen sie viel
besser als ich Luisa Neubau weiß das
auch gg-gesetz genau das gleiche sie
einigen sich und dann reiten sie wieder
raus und sagen alles nicht so gemeint
Atomausstieg alles beschlossen alles so
eingetütet reitet die FDP wieder raus
und sagt alles nicht so gemeint also
wenn sie sagen da gibt es diese Wut und
ich nehme die auch wahr müssen sie da
nicht sagen da haben wir schon auch
einen Anteil daran in der Art und Weise
wie wir diskutieren wie wir Leute vor
allen Dingen verunsichern fragen Sie mal
häuserbesitzer da draußen
Immobilienbesitzer
fragen Sie Leute die die Mietwohnungen
haben oder selber mieten müssen die sind
wahnsinnig verunsichert das hat der mit
der Art und Weise zu tun wie sie
kommunizieren sich selber
persönlich verunsichert wenn die FDP das
Gebäude Energiegesetz durchgewunken
hatte
wie man das machen
Atombombe für die Gesellschaft
ich meine das ist eine Art von
Kommunikation für die man sich ja
entscheidet und es wäre ihr Job es sind
ihre Klimaziele das ist regierungsmäßig
verankert das wäre ihr Job die Menschen
dafür zu begeistern zu zeigen ja das
kann uns nach vorne bringen wir machen
das wir machen es gerecht wir machen es
nachhaltig und effizient statt einem
immer und immer wieder selbst gerecht
werdenden blockierend was wir eben in
ganz weiten Teilen von der FDP in den
letzten zwei Jahren erlebt haben dabei
wäre ja die Chance riesig als liberale
Partei in der Regierung zu sagen wir
sind diejenigen die uns dahinter klemmen
das ist schneller geht das ist
effizienter geht dass er mit dem kleinen
kleinen aufhört dass die Sache man
richtigen drei bekommt und dass wir
aufholen und die ganze verschleppt
Entwicklung nachholen können das wäre
doch ihr Job wir würden uns begrüßen
gerne hören der möglicherweise ganz
anderen Blick auf das Thema Wirtschaft
und diesen Industriestandort hat und
auch auf die Frage warum sind die Leute
eigentlich so wütend
coole sagte kurz vor Beginn der Sendung
war gerade den Bayern unterwegs im
Wahlkampf würde man sagen naja also
Bayern ist ein sehr wohl haben das dann
prosperredendes Land da laufen die Dinge
sehr viel besser als in anderen Teilen
dieser Republik und trotzdem gibt es da
diese unglaubliche Wut haben Sie eine
Idee woher die kommt ja manche Dinge
laufen in Bayern besser manche manche
laufen anders ja sie haben eben gesagt
unterm Strich ist das schon richtig ich
meinte politisch
eben gesagt dass dass die Leute wenn sie
Klimaschutz führen von sozusagen
genug haben genau das ist glaube ich
nicht wirklich wahr in den um in vielen
umfragen sagen die Leute Klimaschutz ist
wichtig wir wollen das wir wollen das
hinkriegen wir sehen ein dass das
passieren muss das Ergebnis dass die
Leute jetzt gerade bei Klimaschutz das
Gefühl haben um Gottes Willen lasst mich
in Ruhe damit ist in erster Linie dieses
muss es so sein verkorks der
heizungsgesetz das von Anfang an nicht
richtig kommuniziert wurde dass die
Leute überrumpelt hat dass
das
von vielen Praktikern dann auch als als
in der Zeit nicht nicht realistisch
angesehen wurde und das ist genau der
Punkt wie man Klimapolitik nicht machen
sollte das ist das Problem dass wenn man
Menschen wie viele in Deutschland die
gerade eh für uns sind durch Krieg durch
Inflation durch Corona die ist auch
nicht gewohnt sind dass die Politik
Ihnen was zumutet beim Klima die letzten
16 Jahre und auch Olaf Scholz hat ja im
Wahlkampf immer gesagt
Klimaschutz ist eigentlich eher ein
Industrieprojekt das soll die Industrie
sich darum kümmern die Menschen halten
wir da erstmal raus wenn man denen was
zumuten will dann muss man es anders
machen dann darf man auch nicht jetzt
sagen
Klimaschutz ist ein politisches
loserthema wie ich es bei ihnen schon
ein bisschen höre sondern da muss man
versuchen den Menschen zu erklären
was man vorhat dass man auch mit den
Menschen was vor die Menschen werden
sich ändern müssen nicht nur bei den
Heizungen und man muss es ordentlich
vorbereiten und das hat die Koalition
nicht hingekriegt sondern sie hat sich
dann ewig bis vor paar Tagen noch
darüber gestritten wie man es macht
damit hat man die Menschen verändert
verärgert nicht mit dem Klimaschutz
selber deswegen finde ich eine
gefährliche Rhetorik wenn man jetzt sagt
wir dürfen kein Klimaschutz mehr machen
nur also das ist auch allerhand weil
also sie können natürlich kritisieren
dass das oder Sie können das nicht
reicht sie können sagen es war von der
Kommunikation her schlecht aber sie
sitzen da am Ende nicht und müssen das
Ding fertig verhandeln und dafür die
Hand heben und sich dafür rechtfertigen
wir machen das im Parlament ich habe
überhaupt kein Problem damit dafür
kritisiert zu werden ich habe kein
Problem damit wenn man sagt dass das
reicht nicht aus der erwarten das
nächste ist alles in Ordnung aber zu
sagen ich wollte keinen Klimaschutz oder
die FDP wollte kein Thema Schutz ist
einfach absolut daneben wir haben gerade
das Gebäude Energiegesetz abgestimmt in
einer Weise wo wir massive Veränderungen
erreicht haben das stimmt und als
nächstes kommt das solarpaket und als
nächstes kommt das Klimaschutzgesetz wir
machen 207 Klimaschutz ja die FDP
erreicht für den Klimaschutz mehr als
mancher Aktivist weil wir ja wirklich da
sitzen und ernsthaft diese Gesetze
verhandelnd über das Engagement von
Aktivisten sprechen muss wenn ich mir
anhören muss Klimaschutz egal dann will
ich einmal sagen dass ich den ganzen Tag
über diese Punkte abstimme und verhandle
und meine Kollegen sehe wie sie sich
wirklich übrigens parteiübergreifen mit
diesem Thema beschäftigen und ich teile
auch die These nicht ich teile die These
nicht dass der Streit in der Ampel der
Hauptgrund für die Verunsicherung beim
Klimaschutz oder in der Gesellschaft ist
dieses Verunsicherung typisch deutsche
Wunsch danach das irgendwie die Politik
einfach sagt so ist es die sind drei
unterschiedliche Parteien aber die
sollen doch einfach mal das soll sich
doch die klügsten zusammensetzen die
machen dann eine Lösung und dann machen
wir das einfach so wie bei Corona am
besten lassen weil die Wissenschaft
regieren und demokratische Parteien und
dann kann man immer einfach das eine
objektiv Richtige tun aber so ist es
nicht in einer Demokratie das muss alles
hart errungen werden und wenn man fürs
Gebäude Energiegesetz abstimmt und dann
fährt man eine Woche später nach Bayern
und hört sich an jedem Wahlkampfstand an
die schrecklich das ist ja dann lasse
ich mir einfach nicht sagen dass wir
nichts zu Klimaschutz
entschuldigen
lassen also wenn man wenn sie sich
anhören müssen wie furchtbar das ist ja
dann müssen sie doch sagen dass sie
durch ihre Art das zu kommunizieren
selbstverständlich auch einen guten Teil
dazu beigetragen haben Entschuldigung so
viel Selbstkritik muss doch mal sein in
dem Originalentwurf stand drin dass die
Leute ihre Heizung ausbauen müssen das
ist abgeschafft worden dass sie der ist
Eigentumsschutz eingeführt worden ja gar
nicht sehen warum ich sehen das erst
hinterher aufgefallen das ist uns nicht
erst hinterher aufgefallen
ich bin Parlamentarier ja denkt sich die
Regierung was aus dann kommt das zu uns
entschuldigen
und dann ist da diese FDP-Minister mit
den haben sie nichts zu tun eigentlich
sein also sie verlangen dass man sich
zusammenrauft und bestimmte Vorschläge
macht und dann ist es auch wieder nicht
richtig also was die Frage ist doch
nicht ob man nicht einen Vorschlag macht
doch die Frage ist doch was geht man
damit um wenn man feststellt ein Gesetz
ist hier noch nicht richtig gut sieht
man dann durch die Medienöffentlichkeit
in Deutschland und hetzt gegen ein Klima
Minister erklärt allerhand von
Schauermärchen wegen morgen von Robert
habe ich persönlich die Heizung
rausgerissen wird oder ist man sich
zusammen und sagt Leute wir müssen hier
ein Land dafür begeistern dass wir eine
wärmewende hinkriegen wir haben hartes
Ziele wir sind europäischer verpflichtet
und wir gucken mal wie können wir das am
besten am innovativ sind
intelligentesten machen ein anderes
gutes Beispiel ganz aktuell was ich
glaube die Lage ganz gut beschreibt ist
die Sache mit dem Klima Geld wir haben
CO2-Preis in Deutschland das übrigens
eine große Errungenschaft von der
Zivilgesellschaft wird weil es für
future haben das vor vier Jahren
gefordert das richtig Druck reingekommen
jetzt gibt's den CO2 Preis das ist ein
wichtiges Instrument sondern
lenkungswirkungen fallen ist dafür aber
nicht heißen es gibt eine CO2-Steuer das
Menschen unterm Strich Geld verlieren
deswegen ist der sozusagen der zweite
Teil von diesem Projekt das Klima Geld
was passiert jetzt gerade es gibt jetzt
den CO2-Preis schon in Deutschland seit
einer seit geraumer Zeit das heißt
anteilig steigen die Preise das forderte
sie auch eine dieser Art von Mechanismus
was kostet das mich jetzt an der Tank an
der Tankstelle im Jahr 2025
plus minus 15 Cent für ein Liter Diesel
das ist für viele Menschen macht es
einen Unterschied das heißt irgendwo
muss kompensiert werden weil nicht alle
Menschen können so schnell umsteigen die
können nicht sofort sagen was macht die
was macht die FDP jetzt das wäre ja sie
werden jetzt ja verantwortlich dafür
digital schnell effizient zu sagen wir
machen das jetzt stellen sie sich hin
und sagen Leute wir haben jetzt schon
jahrelang CO2-Preis klimager Geld kommt
aber nicht vor 20 25 und wenn man sich
dann noch mal anguckt wo das Geld
eigentlich herkommen soll stellt man
fest bis 2027 hat der Herr Minister
Lindner das überhaupt nicht vorgesehen
im klimaan Transformation war das heißt
sie haben keinen Mechanismus wollen den
auch nicht schneller einführen und haben
bisher sich überhaupt nicht darum
gekümmert dass dieses Geld an die
Menschen zurückkommt und das ist der
Augenblick wo Menschen nicht mehr
mitkommt die sagen Moment Klimaschutz
ist wichtig aber die Regierung kann doch
uns nicht Geld wegnehmen für CO2 Preis
und dann mit dem auszahlen so rum
Klavieren und zu tun dass es zu
kompliziert das geht nicht das ist doch
der Moment wo Menschen gar nicht mehr
mitkommen und das ist ja auch was was
mehrheitlich Menschen sagen das Finden
Klimaschutz super aber die haben Angst
abgehängt
das wir sollten das schnell einführen
aber den KTF den
klimatransformationsfonds das ist ja
nicht das Portemonnaie von Herr Lindner
sondern das ist ein vor der von der vom
Bundestag beschlossen worden ist ja von
allem ich habe noch andere
prioritär nutzen würden und das Thema
Geld ich habe
ja gerade verhandelt und dann sagen
gerade jetzt haben jetzt neue
Untersuchung gezeigt dass das nicht
vorgesehen und die Frage ist wo bleibt
der Mechanismus wo ist die FDP die mal
digital loslassen ich bin sehr dafür
dass wir uns jetzt zügig um das
schneller als 20 25
werden
ganz kurz ich bin mit dieser Wut mal
versuchen ein bisschen nachzuspielen ich
habe noch eine andere schlechte
Nachricht für Sie wenn es um die Frage
geht Hilfsgelder Klima Geld wie kommt
das Geld schlicht und ergreifend auf das
Konto der Bürger
auch da glaube ich ist eine Wurzel oder
eine Ursache für diese Wut die die Leute
so umtreibt wie kriegen es allein
verwaltungstechnisch nicht auf die Reihe
wir sind nicht in der Lage Steuernummer
und IBAN also die Bankkonto nur das
zusammenzuführen und Christian Lindner
der Bundesfinanzminister sagt wenn wir
das machen wollen dauert das man
mindestens 18 Monate und die öffentliche
Verwaltung die IT die wir gerade haben
ist in der Lage 100.000 Überweisungen am
Tag vorzunehmen nicht
zufrieden stellen das muss man
verbessern aber das ist ja also das ist
ja nicht so das ist irgendeiner
Digitalisierung die nicht funktionieren
genau
beispielsweise für die Digitalisierung
ja Verwaltung waren 370 Millionen
vorgesehen oder runtergekürzt auf 3
Millionen was ziemlich erbärmlich ist
oder nicht also warum
die Stelle in Deutschland die für den
Kontakt zwischen Staat und Bürger
zuständig ist sind die Länder und die
Kommunen ich weiß und es gibt kaum
Verwaltung des Bundes mehr schlimm wenn
es auch noch mehr verweiterungen
sozusagen geben nebenbei wo der Bund in
Kontakt mit den Bürgern tritt das kommt
ganz selten vor in den Konsulaten
beispielsweise
genau wobei es aber organisiert wird
dann typischerweise über die Länder über
die Kommunen und deswegen ist das ob sie
da im Bund sich um die
verwaltungsdigitalisierung kümmern ja
die Länder die Stellen wo die Auszahlung
stattfindet die müssen digitalisiert
werden ich will das nicht wegschieben ja
aber diese diese eine Reduzierung ist da
jetzt im Haushalt gibt aber kennen das
wird man nicht dazu führen dass das
irgendwie weniger schnell geht schlimm
genug äh die Diskussion darum ist
unfassbar ja sie diskutieren darüber sie
streichen die 370 runter auf 3 Millionen
dann werden sie sozusagen erwischt
Kollegen denken das auf und sagen was
steht denn da jetzt wissen
die die Innenministerin die für die
Digitalisierung zuständig ist es nennt
sie Faser ja also das ist einfach aber
ist doch noch der Bundesfinanzminister
oder nicht er ist der
Bundesfinanzminister aber der Haushalt
wird im Bundestag beschlossen und jeder
mindestens einen Beitrag leisten und es
geht einfach nicht dass wir alle sagen
oh Gott da wird gespart das geht nicht
in meinem Bereich nicht in meinem
Bereich nicht und es müssen eben wir
können auch gerne wenn Sie wollen Nancy
fazer zeigen das macht die Sache aber
nicht besser sie sind Teil dieser
Regierung naja und es gibt
einmal kurz zu Ende erzählen weil es ist
Zeit was die Leute so unfassbar aufregt
sie kürzen ist runter von 370 auf 3
Millionen dann gibt's den Ärger dann
werden sie sozusagen dabei erwischt und
es ist nennt sie Faser in dem Fall ja
Bundesinnenministerium ja die ist dafür
zuständig und findet dann im Keller
sozusagen noch mal 300 Millionen sagt
ach da haben wir doch noch was und dann
nennt man das Ausgaben Rest 4 Milliarden
hat sie sogar im Keller ausreste genau
das versteht kein Mensch mehr verstehen
Sie dass das keiner versteht ja weil ich
selber bist das liegt daran dass
sozusagen in der Haushaltspolitik man
eine Veranschlagung macht das nächste
Jahr man sagt der Staat braucht für den
und den Bereich so und so viel Geld und
dann wird da bestimmte Gelder werden
nicht abgerufen und diese Reste die
summieren sich dann auf und dann kann
man sozusagen darüber im nächsten Jahr
noch was ausgegeben aber die
Haushaltsberatung haben jetzt gerade
erst begonnen und der Bundeshaushalt
wird Ende November abgestimmt im
Bundestag und dann ist erst klar in
welchen Bereichen das tatsächlich so
eine andere schöne Geschichte gelesen
was Elterngeld über
die Bundeszentrale für politische
Bildung also ganz viele Diskussionen
aber was da wie kommt wird erst Ende
November entschieden sie sind ja
Parlamentarier wie sie vorhin zurecht
sagten so ist es sie müssen Auskunft
geben überleben einen künfte so ist es
sie haben neulich an Formular bekommen
diesbezüglich 23 Seiten die sie
ausführen müssen nicht nur Sie sondern
alle anderen auch auf Papier völligere
man muss sogar völliger man muss sogar
20 wenn man das ändern will immer wieder
die neuen 23 Seiten ausfüllen also wenn
man auf Papier ich übernehme jetzt ein
Ehrenamt genau wo ich nicht so bekomme
sondern das ist so ein Beratungs
Ehrenamt und Beirat ja man beim Think
Tank und das muss ja angeben und da kann
ich nicht also ich bin nebenbei um
Europa Rat und da gibt es eine digitale
Maske wo man das dann eingibt dann
kriegt man da drauf dann wird das
angezeigt aber in Deutschland ist es so
dass man alle 23 Seiten ausdrucken muss
und warum sagen Sie mal warum also wir
spielen gerade oder versuchen dieser Wut
auf die Spur zu kommen da da
definitiv also dafür gibt's viele viele
Gründe aus meiner Sicht das erste ist
das in vielen Bereichen die deutsche
analoge Verwaltung immer noch
einigermaßen leistungsfähig ist und
deswegen ja und deswegen der
Leidensdruck
relativ gering ist dass wir glaube ich
recht ja die deutsche Verwaltung ist
deutlich besser als sie gelegentlich
gemacht
das zweite ist dass wir viel zu viele
verschiedene Zuständigkeiten haben also
16 Länder 16
vorgangsbearbeitungssysteme bei der
Polizei haben dann muss ich mich nicht
wundern dass dieses nicht miteinander
austauschen können dann haben wir ein
völlig falsches Verständnis von
Risiko und Einzelfallgerechtigkeit in
Deutschland also es gibt Leute die
einfach jeden Einzelfall geregelt haben
wollen und keine Bereitschaft besteht
mal zu sagen wir probieren mal was aus
immer Risiko ein so und wir haben auch
mitunter ein falsches Verständnis von
Datenschutz ich bin sehr für Datenschutz
aber der Datenschutz darf nicht immer
als ähm ja also am Beispiel darf nicht
immer als Argumenten missbraucht werden
für Dinge die eigentlich mit dem
datenschutzvereinbar sind zum Beispiel
sie ziehen eine Stadt als Studentin ja
Göttingen z.B und gehen zum
Einwohnermeldeamt und melden sich an und
dann müssen sie am gleichen Tag noch zum
Bafög-Amt um sich bei der Bafögstelle
anzumelden dann müsste man doch
eigentlich zur Stadt sagen können du
kannst die Daten gleich darüber schicken
dann wird aber das Amt sagen das dürfen
wir nicht wegen Datenschutz und das ist
quatsch das ist einfach Quatsch weil
Datenschutz heißt datensouveränität wenn
ich meine Einwilligung gebe richtig dann
dürfen die die weitergeben im Grunde
müssen wir verbieten wir müssten es dem
Staat verbieten Daten abzufragen die er
schon hat musst du ein gesetzliches von
der FDP unterstütztes Verbot geben Daten
abzufragen ja ein Verbot ein böses
Verbot ja
gut
wenn er einmal ein Datum erhoben hat das
nicht nochmal wenn Sie ein Verbot dann
darf sie auch eins ja wie man sie
wollten gerade ja ich wollte nur sagen
zur leistungsfähigen Verwaltung es
stimmt natürlich ist die Verwaltung
leistungsfähig und auch besser glaube
ich als an vielen anderen Ländern aber
ich habe zum Beispiel vor einiger Zeit
mit einem Unternehmer geredet der möchte
ein paar Windräder aufstellen in
Ostdeutschland
der hat ähm wusste dazu Anträge stellen
und diese Anträge konnte er nicht in
seinem eigenen Auto
bewegen weil das waren 80 Aktenordner
dafür hatte das heißt er hat einen
kleinen Transportern
geliefert er hat glaube ich sogar extra
mehrere Kopien gemacht damit es dann
andere Behörden auch schon anschauen
könnten weil sonst wäre es noch länger
gedauert also er hat praktisch da auch
für die Behörden sogar schon Kopien
angefertigt die er gar nicht hätte
müssen weil das dann von Behörde zu
Behörde gewandert wäre das sind Zustände
die sind nicht leistungsfähig die sind
im Jahr 2023 auch peinlich und sie
finden immer im Moment wenn sie mit
Unternehmern reden
viele verzweifelte Männer
ich habe ich habe noch ein schönes
Beispiel
Kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz Herr Kohle
sagt den was ich schon mal gehört ja hat
die FDP mit verabschiedet ne sieht vor
ich zitiere mal ja das Betriebe einen
Abfallbeauftragten
zu bestimmen haben geregelt ist das
natürlich in der
abfallbeauftragtenverordnung ab beauf V
abgekürzt der Beauftragte muss besonders
qualifiziert sein und regelmäßig an
Schulungen teilnehmen ein großer Aufwand
natürlich für die Betriebe weil
möglicherweise fällt ja gar nicht so
viel Abfall an und am Ende hat der
müllexperte zudem nur eine beratende
Funktion weil hauptverantwortlich für
den Müllentsorgung bleibt weiterhin der
Chef ja und da der Ausnahme dieser
Pflicht zur Bestellung eines
Abfallbeauftragten zu beantragen
bedeutet wiederum ein riesigen
bürokratischen Auftrag das heißt Sie
können nicht einfach sagen wir haben
heute mal keinen Abfall Auftritten
solche Gesetze verabschieden sie und sie
mit als FDP was was geht denn das geht
an einem vor also wir laufen eine
Situation rein in der
das Maß an Regulierung das Unternehmen
einhalten müssen irgendwann so groß sein
wird dass wir Gefahr laufen dass die
Leute sich nicht mehr dran halten weil
sie einfach nicht mehr überblicken und
das ist ein Beispiel ich werde momentan
viel angesprochen auf das Hinweisgeber
Schutzgesetz ja wo auch Meldestellen
eingerichtet werden müssen ab einer
bestimmten Größe Hinweisgeber
Schutzgesetz zurück auf die
Whistleblower Richtlinie der
Europäischen Union wenn bestimmte
Missstände bestehen also zum Beispiel
ein Unternehmen gibt Abfälle in der
abfallbeauftragte möglich
jemanden der vielleicht das an die
Öffentlichkeit durchsticht oder die
Strafe Verfolgungsbehörden dann soll
diese Person geschützt werden
vernünftige so und wir haben uns dafür
eingesetzt als das Ding umgesetzt worden
ist dass das nicht für kleine
Unternehmen geht sondern wirklich erst
für diejenigen die vielleicht jemanden
finden ja der sich darum kümmern kann
aber es geht gar nicht um die
Einzelfälle wir haben jetzt gelacht über
diesen Abfallbeauftragten es geht um die
traurig werden
die Masse an Regeln und es geht darum
das Politiker dieses Wort
Bürokratieabbau im Munde führen die
Partei sie sie sind doch die in die
sagen wir bauen das ab ja die FDP steht
sie haben den Abfallbeauftragten haben
sie mitfahrgelegt mit reinnehmen nein
also das Bürokratie entlastungsgesetz
das muss man vorbereitet sieht vor über
400 Vorschläge aus der Wirtschaft die
wir uns angesehen haben und bei denen
wir gerade dabei sind ein
Zusammenstellung zu machen was alles weg
kann nur ich will ihn etwas sagen ja wir
haben kluge Leute hier versammelt die
sich mit Themen wie Bio Universität
beschäftigen wenn man jetzt anfängt zu
sagen wir schaffen diesen beauftragten
abgeschlossen jeden beauftragten ab dann
garantiere ich gibt es immer Leute die
sagen dann den einen können wir nicht
abschaffen und deswegen ist es immer
eine Frage der Gesamtbelastung für die
Unternehmen und es ist eben sehr einfach
dahin gesagt wir machen jetzt mal
Bürokratie abbauen dann muss ich dann
auch trauen in bestimmten Bereichen
Bürokratie abzubauen vielleicht darf ich
noch ein Beispiel geben wir haben als
Ampel
in der Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung
eingeführt das Großprojekte durchgeführt
werden können auch wenn es einen kleinen
Mangel gibt ja also Straßenbau
Brückenbau und so weiter und sie haben
vielleicht ein Hektar Ausgleichsfläche
zu wenig Ausgleichsfläche wichtig wegen
Biodiversität dann kann der Richter
zukünftig sagen das ist nur ein kleiner
Mangel macht mal weiter und die
Ausgleichsfläche macht ihr später als
wäre das in den Bundestag eingebracht
haben eine ganz viel Post bekommen und
auch im Bundestag Leute die sich zu Wort
gemeldet haben was soll denn das sein
ein nur
unerheblicher Mangel was soll das sein
der kann ein absehbarer Zeit verbessert
werden das sind ja zwei unbestimmte
Begriffe das ist ja rechts Unsicherheit
das muss alles genau geregelt werden
also ist unsere Gesellschaft auch bereit
für Bürokratie abbauen das würde ich mir
wünschen das wird nämlich risikober
Bereitschaft und weniger Einzelfall
Gerechtigkeit voraussetzen also brauchen
wir und dann können wir auch machen